nous sommes en 1921 à greenwood une
banlieue d'environ dix mille âmes au
nord de tulsa la deuxième plus grande
ville d'oklahoma dans le sud des états
unis
il se trouve que green wood est un
quartier noir est même l'un des plus
prospères du pays attirant de riches
entrepreneurs noirs et jouissant d'une
économie florissante
on surnomme même cet endroit le black
wall street of america enfin ça c'est
non donné aujourd'hui car à l'époque on
parlait plutôt dans la presse locale de
[ __ ] au wall street
car oui nous sommes dans les années 20
et le racisme et la ségrégation sont
toujours de mise à tout ça à ce moment
là la lois jim crow qui interdit aux
noirs d'accéder au bâtiment réservé aux
blancs il y a encore cours de plus la
réussite de greenwood apparaît comme une
insulte aux yeux de nombreux habitants
blancs notamment ceux revenus de la
grande guerre et qui souffre de la
concurrence noir sur le marché du
travail
ajoutez à cela la présence du klu klux
klan et vous avez là tous les
ingrédients du cocktail explosif qui va
mener aux événements qu'on a appelé le
massacre de tulsa le 30 mai 10 921 dit
crosland un cireur de chaussures afro
américain de 19 ans trébuche
malencontreusement sur sarah paige 17
ans et surtout blanche
dès le lendemain il est arrêté pour vous
donner une idée de l'ambiance qui règne
à ce moment le tulle sa tribune titre ce
jour là je cite un [ __ ] attrapés pour
avoir attaqué une fille dans un
ascenseur de là tout s'emballe
une foule blanche réclame rowland pour
le lyncher des patrouilles noir armée
s'organise pour les en empêcher
les deux groupes se font face un premier
coup de feu est tiré la suite c'est
viola fletcher plus anciennes survivante
qui la raconte mais la nuit du massacre
j'ai été réveillé par ma famille mes
parents à mes cinq frères et soeurs et
des larmes des votes sont m'a dit que
nous devions partir et c'est tout je
n'oublierai jamais la violence de la
foule blanche lorsque nous avons quitté
notre maison
je vois encore des hommes noirs se faire
tirer dessus décor noir gisant dans la
rhune ce que lui
* je sens dans la fumée je vois encore
le feu je vois encore des commerces noir
brûlé
j'entends encore les avions volaient au
dessus de nos têtes
j'entends les cris j'ai vécu au
quotidien avec le souvenir de ce matin à
l'aube du 1er juin greenwood est envahie
par une foule blanche de plusieurs
milliers de personnes
le quartier est presque entièrement rasé
les commerces sont pillés quelques 1250
logements sont détruits parfois à l'aide
d'avions lâchant des bombes incendiaires
une demi douzaine d'églises une école le
seul hôpital de la ville et plus de 130
entreprises sont réduites en cendres le
bilan humain officiel est de 45 morts en
réalité un rapport de 2001 leur évalue
entre 100 et 300 victimes et il pourrait
être bien plus élevé encore les
habitants de greenwood eux n'ont jamais
obtenu réparation greenwood aurait dû
avec ma chance de réussir dans ce cas
dans quelques heures tout ceci a disparu
je suis ici pour demander justice et je
demande à mon pays de reconnaître ce qui
s'est passé à tout ça en 1921 à cause du
massacre à ma famille a été chassé de
notre maison à 11 oui mais nous n'avions
plus rien oui nous sommes devenus des
réfugiés dans notre propre pays
quand cette histoire longtemps oubliés
est réapparu au début des années 2000 et
le 100e anniversaire du massacre de
tulsa revêt une symbolique toute
particulière aux états unis alors qu'un
autre anniversaire celui de la mort de
jack floyd il y a un an vient d'être
commémoré